ma serve a tutti i ragazzi e benvenuti
avessero video sono quello la che fai
video don rocco siffredi l'altro quello
che fa da tutti ragazzi ho dato
un'occhiata a tutto quello che avete
scritto ho deciso di fare questo
episodio sulle cose che mi avete detto
voi in cercare nella challenge di video
correlati se non lo sapete come funziona
non c'ho voglia di spiegare in tutti i
fottuti simi episodi guardate libri
vecchi avete considerato sacro da carino
mi fanno strani bere e tra l'altro sono
difficilissime cioè io quello che ho
fatto ci ho messo una vita a farlo ed
erano abbastanza facile nel inventavo io
adesso è difficile
partiamo dal più semplice tra tutte
quelle che avete consigliato perché non
è più semplice da fa vj a rocco siffredi
sarà bene il tuo casino
[Musica]
a trovare rocco su youtube è un problema
però va beh vediamo quindi appunto io
partiamo dal titolo nel titolo esserci
sito rocco e non i canali di rocco nel
tipo allora siamo già tuffa vj perché
rocco cia un canale youtube capito
shotout a rocco siffredi ragazzi aspetto
solo che rocco fascia non sua auto a me
a del successo tout che mi nomini per me
sarebbe un onore
restiamo comunque a degenerare allora
questo mi sembra un'ottima copertina per
iniziare sto gioco indecente
andiamo su sull'indecenza e se vediamo
se riusciamo ad uscire dal perché io
tratto solo un limbo in questo gioco al
primo video di faringei poi è un casino
perché non riesce a i consigliati sono
tutti miei quindi porca vacca devo
uscire dal limbo fa vj quindi ipantellas
forse li ha mossi pantella su shamo
proprio dalla vita teoricamente non
riuscire a farlo in meno click possibili
però la vedo dura dura
mica l'ho detto a caso allora ipantellas
fanno un sacco di cose sconce quindi
potrebbe anche essere ragazzi dietro è
gold cup e di si parla di cup quindi può
essere applichiamo sul cap perfetto
bravo den io lo prenderei come un
complimento con sé nei panteras che sto
passando da loro per arrivare al rocco e
cioè non è da tutti io non ho idea dei
format di rocco non lo non so se fa
gameplay non sospetti penso proprio di
no però non so come arrivano noi denis
come arrivare a rocco siffredi non ho
idea di allora aspetta che sto cercando
di capire che qualche no veramente
ragazza impossibile cioè non puoi
arrivare a rocco così è veramente
acquitato so cliccando su continua de
sipán te la sei così a soli cantella
salame contro te mi sa che ci
allontaniamo e di bestie anche i giorni
since johnny since johnny since siamo
già quasi li siamo già così non sarà che
se si pronuncia così chi se ne frega
tanto io non devo pronunciare devo solo
guardare uno scherzo d'acqua è facile
cavolo non so tra l'altro come sono
arrivato qua impossibili giri
allucinanti si paolo bra paolo brosio
pro paolo brosio paolo brosio quello da
uscire madonna diletta leotta miss c'è
ma dai
proprio lui proprio lui lo trova lo
cerca proprio lì il rocco nazionale cioè
soa tantissimo ma tantissimo è stato
molto più difficile e questo era più
facile di tutti pensate un saluto al
nostro batte e andiamo avanti ragazzi mi
avete suggerito da dora l'esploratrice a
stranger things che ho scelto tra tutte
un'altra abbastanza semplice perché
questa poi mi ha messa a dura prova
quindi un attimo di calma alla governo
[Musica]
come evitare d'ora l'esposto di partiva
da questo ok ai ragazzi siamo da
veramente arrivare a stringerti nice
deve essere un casino di quelli
allucinanti anche perché non vedo come
sanno cosa centrare con dora
l'esploratrice però cosa c'entra
costringe artista cosa dove prende
fleece netflix quindi netflix quindi
netflix cerchiamo netto e allora serie
tv no tv ci sono archita tv clicchiamo
su tv la parola tv potrebbe essere
strettamente collegata a netflix vediamo
bellissimo poi siamo passati dalla roba
di prive di rocco anta e sottil
occupiamo trarre qualche sei centri con
netflix in tutto questo la vedi un
attimo a ecco tipo questo penso già un
killer questo è un teaser questo è un
teaser quindi già da qua meno male che
hanno fatto il film meno vale già da qua
teoricamente siamo su netflix ok quindi
qualcosa che abbia che fai con netflix
teoricamente avremmo dovremmo finire su
strani già tease in qualche modo tra
l'altro uscito non troppo tempo fa il
trailer quello dove si vede ma poi
abbiamo dice abbiamo tutte adesso have
it to the game therapy quello è e tranne
quella che ci serve sicura e distrutto
lo sfondo ma ne vale la pena
questo è un record tra tutti quanti
teoricamente perché ci ho messo
veramente poco bravo me c'è meno
distanza tra d'ora l'esploratrice e
strange things che tra me e rocco questa
cosa mi rende triste
facciamone ancora una ragazzi questo è
difficile come se la tele mostrano
faccia da joker ha acqua rocchetta bombe
[Musica]
avrò paolo brosio sul picco paolo grossi
scusarmi perché paolo brosio è ovunque
non c'è un
paolo brosio da paolo crosia joker
ancora peggio è il khobar da checco
zalone forze con lui becco film e con
film non so allora da qua da qua
maverick quindi offrendo il primo
inglese fin inglese che c'è ok adesso
dovrebbe essere abbastanza semplice
perché abbiamo siamo sul cinema
americano quindi da qua da top gun del
reggimento e con i star ci siamo e mi
chiedo adesso rocky balboa paolo brosio
finalmente è da tempo che non lo vedevo
grazie che mi avete rimesso morbius e
xvi suisse batman non buttate di batman
da guido sezione novità eccola qua è
vero non la clicchiamo perché voglio
vedere se riesco a farlo in pochi click
joker andrea bash solo con rocco fatto
casino per il resto abbastanza healy
va bene facevano ancora un'altra allora
mi sembra abbastanza fattibile data a
questa non l'ho beccata subito perché
non sapevo di cosa si trattasse però
adesso vediamo da johnny johnny gli ex
papa
magari a fabri fibra però devo capire
cos'è giorni giorni yes papa vi giuro
non lo so vediamo
[Musica]
ok forse era meglio lasciar perdere
quanto quanto quanto non raga non è
possibile
3 miliardi 3 miliardi di b usa fatto sta
loro ok ricomponiamo c'è questa fatto le
ville del mio canale intero quasi
[Musica]
allora torniamo un attimo torniamo a
vinchio blippy clip richiamo blippy
perché ne dà un po ei uscire da questo
circolo satanico non è così facile
quindi dovremmo uscire in qualche modo
da blippy se spuntasse paolo grossi
adesso sarebbe incredibile anche da
paolo preferiamo alla machete in batte
royal da quell'aria fabric in questi
collegamenti certo se si mettessero
qualcosa che non sia per bambini 0 anni
sarebbe meglio niente almeno italiano
almeno quello manco tutto un colore nut
fondali o sempre papig peppa pig non c'è
una roba che non si sa ma una anche una
canzone una canzone che da lì poi mi
collego ad altro che niente tutto
bambini centri youtube keats ragazzi è
finita dentro il kit è finita non fa più
niente proprio deve stare in galera
la galera non si può uscire di qua non
si può uscire da qua
l'unico modo e cliccare su una live
questo è da e dal vivo supplicando su
una live per poi andare su un'altra live
magari di uno che non è
si può tutto questo ok ma tra forno rega
niente sempre bambini un casino
no raga dal kiss non puoi uscire bagato
non è che bagato è voluto perché i
bambini che stanno su youtube non
vogliono farli uscire dal kitsch quindi
se tu entri col keats non vuoi uscire a
chi è un po come fight club campani o
giabbani h perché a me montana
giustamente me la pesca o come contro i
backstreet boys
c'è però kabanga barney è la cosa più
vicina a tutte quelle che ho visto
virata hg che noi ci siamo ragazzi ci
siamo allora fedez eccolo fede quasi ci
siamo quasi
perché più o meno j ax ragazza adesso
siamo veramente vicini
adesso stiamo bene così vicini così non
lo so ti prego ti prego di marrakech
fatto fabbri recente dio mio
eccolo proprio a lui
però vi sia piaciuto continuiamo nel
prossimo video correlati challenger per
adesso concludo qua mamma mia
consigliati di con i commenti altre
correlazioni da cercare nel prossimo
episodio e noi come sempre ci vediamo al
occasioni e da ragazzi
[Musica]